what is disruption wrecking destroying
cracking open out with the old in with
the new innovation taxis with human
drivers set to be replaced by autonomous
vehicles big factories with jobs that
involve heavy lifting forget it
let robots do the work disruption is not
a new phenomenon steam ships for example
replaced sailing ships and horse-drawn
carriages gave way to cars Wikipedia
made print encyclopedias look quaint
while digital cameras finished off 35
millimeter film the drawback old
companies like Kodak went bust and lots
of people lost their jobs the advantage
everything speeded up got cheaper and
for some ideas fortunes were just a
click away like Airbnb it acts as a
broker for private rooms and departments
but doesn't own a single hotel or employ
an army of staff the internet company is
currently worth thirty 1 billion dollars
to compare bricks and mortar Hotel Group
Hilton is worth just twenty five billion
is the day of the bellboy over eclipsed
by the era of the programmer
technological advances often spread
disruption in their wake but markets
grow out of disruption and leaders and
new fields can quickly establish near
monopolies like Google and Microsoft did
then small startups can't compete
because industry giants develop ideas on
their own but even they aren't ever
really safe because at any time
disruption could always come along and
crack their industry wide open